[Laughter]
[Music]
hey what's up y'all I'm Kelly Clarkson
and today I'm gonna do the try not to
laugh challenge but with ice-t cuz I'm
southern I'm calling it don't spill the
tea you see what we did there almost got
me with that one that chicks bunny her
teeth are awesome it really smells like
a public restroom you know what
hmm no well maybe she likes to taste
public restrooms what was she drinking
Oh
kombucha oh I like what the hell kind of
animal is that does it say what it is
what kind of animal is that it's like a
creature of Lord like it's like nobody
knows what it is but it was freaky and
cute I kind of want one
[Laughter]
neck hole hole hey cool hey can you grab
the cheese it before I call security I'm
not kidding I'm not kidding at all I'm
serious what was real cool
[Music]
do you see the cheese it was no security
if you're a drunk you want like a burger
it's a substance that damn cheese it
what you gonna do it chase it if it's
just a team okay that's all of them I
didn't spill the tea I think what we
found out here today peoples that I'm
awesome you're welcome
this has been don't spill the tea which
I didn't that's right I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this